why would you who has a dating coach
what's 35 years old and you've got a
dating coach
i mean at 35 don't you know how to date
or doesn't a dating coach tell you don't
take out your phone no you see this is
the problem like this is a reptile fact
so or basically like a hundred percent
of women want twenty percent of men
so girls have been going through their
their twenties and they're even their
early thirties like they're side chicks
yeah and so they've never really had any
relationship experience so they don't
know how to like vet men properly
and so it's like they get to 35 and
they're still like mentally a teenager
because they've never had a real
relationship
and so it's like yeah so that's like
what you see is she's mentally still a
teenager
a lot of them yeah there's a lot and an
elder and that's why like you can't have
a conversation about like hey it's not
about happiness like that's an adult
conversation but like it's like you're
talking to teenagers but you know what
sooner or later it's gonna balance
itself out the mental women ratio
because the men are going to realize
that half of your women are stupid if
you don't want you and it's going to
even itself up
and then you're going to end up
lonely and barren with your dogs no
that's what happens yeah like i don't i
don't see like i don't see
her getting like saved unless like she
changes her behavior but like i just
don't see it happening because she
looked like here i'll keep up like even
me she's very dominarian yeah even here
i'll keep who is your dating coach
married yes because she has a baby and
her wedding ring is at least five carats
yeah
and her man is rich excuse me okay you
know he herself makes like 30 to 50
grand a month coaching women in love
i mean good luck if that like works for
you i just like to me that sounds like
a 200k engagement ring like i think like
guys are gonna hear that and be like no
no you have to have the man who's okay
with me maintaining you
right with maintaining you right like
you can be high maintenance but if you
are dating a man that is okay with
maintaining you you're fine you're not
high maintenance then you're just on
their level
okay but i'm i'm just thinking like
like
i i know but those guys that are making
like
like that amount of money like
like i think they typically
want like the young like 21 22 year olds
i don't think so
maybe
what
i'm 30. so i'm not that old i'm actually
no i don't age to be wiped up by
somebody who's like in their 40s and
like ready to be serious and start
popping out babies a 21 year old unless
you're kylie jenner is realistically too
young to be like popping out kids
like you're too young
yeah i mean that's just i'm sorry the
200 000 like that's crazy to me it was a
lot nicer than these people have tried
my pleasure she's just like there's
something living in her she's scary look
at her she looks possessed
she's not right no seriously she's like
yeah
she's not no
no no
and you know what that reminds me of she
right there when she was talking
she reminded me of my niece
and my niece is about uh seven eight
minutes i'm gonna get me this my dad's
gonna get me that this is what that's
what she sounded like an impotent child
they're mentally like like kids well my
friend's got a ring like that so i'm
gonna get a ring like that and if she
can get one then i can
and that's what she's going on she
showed me what her like friend looked
like
her friend was hot
like i'm sorry you get hot girl
privilege
like i i just think a lot of times girls
that are like fives
take advice from girls that are eights
but the eights can get away with [ __ ]
the fives can't
you said that
she's single yeah
she's never in a day is she a
virgin she's an undercover [ __ ]
that's not my main school oh probably
she's she's an undercover because what
else because all she's doing is scoring
herself out to the highest bidder yeah i
mean what else has she been doing for
the last decade like you've had 10 years
plus working her way up to sleep in the
way up to the top but she's never gonna
get there
but that's that's the thing is like
she's like a five she's probably
sleeping with eight but that's that's
what i'm saying the modern woman is a
side chick
they're just gonna look at her for a bit
of fun
yeah that's what i'm saying the modern
one because she thinks that she's eye
candy she's not eye candy no no
i can't do it fairly
no sir you can be eye candy at 30 if
you're dating a 60 year old yeah you're
right candy because i've dated an older
guy and everybody else i wasn't feeling
good about myself at that time he was a
fantastic man and somebody goes for me
jennifer why are you going up such an
older man
i said because i'm always going to look
better than a woman his age
which is true
it made me feel good for a while you
know and that's what it was is that i
was feeling bad about myself and like
compared to a woman i'm gonna i'm always
gonna look good
but
it was just childish i don't even think
she'll date that old either
that's like
oh my gosh i cannot believe that's crazy
someone that can make that amount of
money in a shorter period of time like
somebody who would say a musical artist
right a musical producer somebody who's
in entertainment somebody who's on a tv
show somebody who does like concerts and
tours that amount of money
isn't
the same
to them you know what i
do
mean
what do you mean
like say i was dating somebody like a g
easy right okay he makes 150 000 minimum
per show minimal that's what he makes in
a show yeah so if he does a couple shows
the 200 grand to him he won't even feel
it now let me show you g-eazy's
ex-girlfriend let me just because she
she said g-eazy hates luke
of men that they deserve
this is who she's talking about if she
was to date a g-eazy that's his
ex-girlfriend
i know that like the raw i know like the
the like that's not a good look like the
way she dresses but like she's stunning
like that is a stunning girl and you you
think you're he's not even old he's is
he a stylist yeah he's a star that's
what i'm saying i'm saying like he's not
even huh i wouldn't even she the girls
huh yeah yeah but i'm saying that guy
can get girls like that you're not going
to have the same results
this is something coming from someone
like i've been in a relationship with a
guy that was worth over a million
like i've i but i would never know she's
going to spend 200k on a rank
like to me that's like that's almost
like entitled like i'm not entitled to
his money i
i mean
here's the thing if i can afford it
myself
i will i would want you to be able to
get it for me right yeah get it myself
wow oh my gosh that's just
yeah i guess like we kind of probably
have different like
spending habits because to me i'm like i
would even if i had the money i would
never spend that on a ring
like this she's serious she is dead
serious
but i'm also not that much of a jewelry
person right so it's like you're not
going to need to be buying me diamonds
for every anniversary or
jewelry all the time like get me my ring
and that's it i don't really need much
else
hi oh gosh sorry
oh hi nikki i just added you to it
who is that purposely not putting your
camera around get me
i mean if you spend 200 calories
i hope i hope he gets you nothing ever
again 200k
oh my god the [ __ ] you don't you know i
don't if you want something buy yourself
love if you can't buy yourself why are
you gonna expect somebody else to buy it
for you 200k ring
okay
no i have to like connect it to the
thing hold on
i've done like a youtube live with her
she's
uh oh well
we'll go in a minute
sorry
i can i can drop you if this is a bad
time i just thought i'd add you to the
chat
no just real quickly because we got
dinner and lamb and all this other good
stuff
listen
this i love this life this is hilarious
i love you with the girls asking for
300k diamond rings and everything on
this one these guys are now saying that
women hit the wall at age 20. and you're
talking about the 200 000 they'll be
like oh god
but you guys are both women they're both
women so you really don't know
like how would you know but like being
around is being just uh like a lot of
these men they seem like they're in la
and it's like the people that they're
talking about is like who are you
meeting so as
two people are coming with completely
different expectations and like when you
were saying earlier you have pointed out
the person that was in the yoga class
she had a three hundred thousand dollar
ring the person your coach she has a
three hundred thousand dollar ring it
wasn't like base the reason the ring
that i have i wanted it because of the
fact that growing up
some there's a certain type of thing in
my family that that's what it was but it
wasn't because any of my friends had
that ring i couldn't care less what they
had so no i don't want it because they
have it i know i can have it because
they have it do you understand what i'm
saying like i understand that oh
hundred thousand dollar to two hundred
thousand dollar eight carat diamond
engagement ring is within my grasp
because i've seen it in real life
i associate with people who have these
things they're in my circles of people
they're in my friend groups
and i know i can have it because i've
seen it not it's not that i want it
because they have it i want it and then
i've seen it i've seen validation of it
in my in front of my face